all right guys bang bang I've got an
awesome group here with us uh I thought
maybe the first place we could start
will reflexivity and elementus came
together they did this year review of
onchain activity uh and the first
question you guys hammer on is what
exactly is making bitcoin's price go up
as we went into the beginning of the
year help us understand what you guys
found yeah absolutely this was a really
exciting report that we put together uh
there's a ton of kind of year in review
reports but I don't think anyone's done
one from from an onchain perspective so
we're excited to to put this out as you
mentioned the the first thing we kind of
dived into was kind of breaking down
what's Driven uh bitcoin's price
performance throughout 2023 so you know
if you don't live under a rock you've
probably seen that Bitcoin has been one
of the best performing assets of of the
entire year and you kind of look at it
aggregated measured against equities as
opposed to individual equities uh it is
the best performing asset class or was
the best performing asset class of of
2023 and there's a couple kind of
factors that have been driving that you
know one is just mean revers after
Bitcoin and crypto got beat down so bad
you've got kind of an inflection point
uh in the liquidity cycle and then also
the biggest one is kind of front running
of of the recent Bitcoin ETF approval
and launches uh that that we saw over
the last couple weeks and people been
continue to to keep a close eye on and
we break that down into kind of data to
to try to kind of build a picture of the
type of Market participant that's been
driving Bitcoin over the last call it
you know 12 to 12 to 15 months there's a
couple interesting kind of subsets that
we can break it down into um and in the
report we broke it down into three one
is onchain capital flows primarily
looking at flows around coinbase the
second is activity by Geographic trading
session uh and the third is activity
within the derivatives landscape so
maybe PP we we dive into first of all
looking at uh some of this onchain kind
of capital flows um particularly uh
around coinbase so in this first chart
We have basically um a month over month
a chart of coinbase prime uh and and the
amount of Bitcoin held within coinbase
Prime um and so what we can see is that
uh throughout the year we've seen a
continued increase in the amount of
Bitcoin held within coinbase Prime what
does this indicate um alongside the the
transaction volumes Pi picking up um it
signals that there's more activity uh
taking place within uh coin bases Prime
in custodial arms and that shows an
increased amount of activity from this
kind of USB institutional cohort that
particularly you know uses uses coinbase
uh when we look at coinbase relative
some of the other Crypton native venues
uh coinbase is well known for being kind
of the most regulated publicly traded uh
you know top five accounting firm
audited exchange relative to maybe some
of the the other venues offshore that
are a bit more kind of in the realm of
of kind of wild west uh and so you know
a lot of these uh us-based hedge funds
High net worths uh family offices Etc
like to use coinbase as opposed to some
of the other venues so maybe that's some
some good context on why we're looking
at coinbase in particular here uh so
we've got the picture kind of being
painted of you know increased amount of
Bitcoin held in uh coinbase custody as
well as um their their Prime arm as well
and then when we look at flows within
the two as well we see very similar
Dynamic of we saw continued outflows
from coinbase Prime uh particularly
leading up uh right after the the Black
Rock filing um into the actual ETF
launch so um you know that that looks
like a lot of kind of front running of
the ETF um and then when we shift over
to uh the kind of geographic trading uh
premiums this another really interesting
point to kind of uh hammer on in terms
of looking at the type of type of Market
participant that we saw throughout 2023
uh in the chart that we have in the
report uh we have the US trading hour uh
basically cumulative return uh and then
we also have APAC and then EU and so
what we can see is that particularly
after uh the initial Black Rock filing
in July of of 23 we saw that the US
trading hour premium really started to
show relative to AAC in in the EU and so
that's just another data point to kind
of illustrate that uh you know bitcoin's
rally throughout the back half of 23 uh
was primarily driven uh by these
us-based firms and then the last one um
that I thought was also really
interesting was shifting over to the
derivatives landscape U looking at
activity around the CME so the CME um
you know very similar to how coinbase is
used as the the spot exchange of choice
relative to some of the other offshore
venues the CME is um is is used by
primarily kind of you know regulated
us-based hedge funds institutions Etc as
opposed to you know trading Perpetual
swaps on some of these offshore venues
uh you know in particular you know
traditional Financial players are
probably going to use CME as opposed to
you know maybe going to use a buy bid or
a binance uh and so this is an
interesting signal for the activity uh
taking place you know by those by those
uh that cohort of of Market participants
and so what we saw throughout 2023 uh
once again particularly after um the
filing for Black Rock in July of 23 is a
massive uptick in both Futures uh open
interest and volume on the CME uh we saw
this shoot up uh from right around two
billion to reaching all-time highs of
over six billion um in the chart you
you'll be able to see basically this
this massive run up uh following the the
filing in July and so this is kind of
another piece of information to kind of
construct this picture of who really
kind of drove drove Bitcoin up uh
throughout the year and so you know our
our kind of thesis through through
putting all these data points together
about the the type of Market participant
uh throughout 23 is is basically
painting this image of um at the
beginning of of bitcoin's kind of
lifespan it was particularly you know um
uh kind of cryptographers and and very
much um you know people that were Deep
In The Weeds about um you know building
out something similar to bitcoin and
then latched onto Bitcoin once it was
clear that that was kind of the best
form of of uh Sovereign you know scarce
money that was ever created that was
that was digitally native um as we kind
of progressed throughout bitcoin's
lifespan then it kind of shifted towards
retail High net worths um you know over
the last couple years we started to see
some hedge funds and um some of these
trafi players start to dip their toes in
the water but I think it's pretty clear
throughout 2023 that the dominating type
of Market participant that really
Bitcoin up was this kind of us-based uh
perhaps you know more ntional Finance
oriented type of
player so it's fascinating to look at
this data um but how you get the data I
think it's a pretty important question I
think maybe Max uh element is obviously
the technology you guys have built
allows you to uh provide incredible
attribution to these wallets
understanding Capital flows and there's
a lot of the things that will is talking
about here is kind of the analysis or
conclusions are driven by this
technology of mapping wallets describe a
little bit as to how elementus does this
sure well i' say at the very highest
level there are two components to it
there is the clustering and the
attribution piece so the clustering I
would Define as just um data science
methods for figuring out which addresses
roll up into the same owner and there's
a lot of different ways of approaching
that um different kinds of urtic uh that
you there's lots of academic papers out
there that you can look online about
some of the base methods for doing that
um that's where the majority of our
technology sits and so the methods that
we use uh go quite deep to be able to
connect wallets together so for
something like a say coinbase coinbase
the exchange they have called 100
million addresses on the Bitcoin
blockchain um our mission with them is
to be able to um identify the Wallets on
chain and understand the connections and
to be able to group them all into kind
of one entity uh now from that point we
need to be able to go out then and say
okay we have this network work of 100
addresses that are all the same actor um
like who is this and for that we need to
go out and be able to put a label on it
so that's the attribution piece and how
do you find out who it is like what are
some of the ways or methods that you
would use to do that well easiest way
would be for for a coinbase you just
sign up for a coinbase you deposit small
amount of Bitcoin now you have one
coinbase address and then you can
extrapolate that and say okay the other
99.999 million addresses are also a
coinbase
uh when you get to some of the other
entities that are not quite so easy to
sign up for if you're talking about
something some of like the legal stuff
darket markets ransomware or even if
you're talking about like
institutional um buyers hedge funds um
some of these kind of actors you know
those ones not as easy to identify by by
just signing up and interacting with so
for those um you know we have to get
clever in our in our approaches but um
and so as you've done this uh as part of
this report there's this entire
breakdown of wallet activity walk us
through a little bit as to what some of
the conclusions from that analysis is
today's episode is brought to you by
espresso the maker of the world's
thinnest portable display now listen up
if you're like me you feel like you are
at a command center when you sit down at
your desk I got a gazillion tabs open
and different windows for different
activities there's my web browser my
text messages I've slack open and I got
a Notes app I normally work on a desktop
and it can be very very productive but
and everything falls apart the second I
leave my desk if I'm traveling if I go
to a coffee shop to do some work or just
want to work from the kitchen table my
laptop doesn't have enough screen space
I lose my command center and my
productivity falls off a cliff it's a
major problem but this is where espresso
comes in they have a portable screen
that is so beautiful that you think
Steve Jobs came back from the dead to
create it the thing is incredibly light
it comes with a nice stand and the user
interface is so easy that I figured out
how to do it in less than 3 minutes if
you listen to this podcast you know
that's not an easy feat so the espresso
team and I we became friends I got to
know them cuz I really like the product
and those screens they now want to offer
them to any fan of the podcast so we
struck a little deal here's how it works
anyone who listens to this podcast can
go to
us.
P.O or that's too confusing just go
click the link in the description if you
go to espresso's website they've got a
brand new offer there sitting for you
you get a little discount and you'll get
a beautiful screen trust me I use mine
every day you'll love the espresso
screen and I think it'll make you more
productive go check them out today by
clicking on the link in the description
yeah okay so yeah this is a really
interesting one so you know my
background I I come from um a background
in in trafi so I worked for for nine
years at Deutsche Bank and credit spe as
a Trader I traded tons of fixed income
markets so you know I was on the front
lines and looking at every piece of
information that was out there for
understanding markets seven screens in
front of me I was on top of everything
uh what this represents is something
something that's not even possible in
trafi which is that you can look across
the entire market and you can see what
the cost basis is with the average cost
basis is for everyone who holds Bitcoin
right and that's because you can see
when the positions were put on you know
the price of Bitcoin at that time so you
know what that person has in that trade
so what this is looking at is the
average cost basis at which Bitcoin is
held on the market so it's actually
quite intuitive if you look down to the
chart on page 13 the market value to
realized value so what this is looking
at is um well it's comparing what did
the average person pay for Bitcoin
versus what is the current price of
Bitcoin so how much how much profit do
people have in the market and what
you'll see is that is that occasionally
the market price for bit Bitcoin will
drop slightly below um that cost basis
number but it it tends to stay there for
only a very short period of time right
because you know presumably people are
not willing to sell at a price below
which they um the price of which they
purchased it so uh this is is a
remarkably reliable
indicator um which um you know this is
we're looking over here here over a 10-e
Time Horizon and um even though those
kind of opportunities don't appear all
that often um Trend seems to be uh near
100% uh accurate that when you see
Bitcoin Delow dip below the cost basis
that is a very strong Buy
Signal and when you guys look at this um
obviously there's uh a lot of onchain
data providers right that are kind of uh
selling that data but uh the attribution
and um the the collection that you all
are doing can be used for a multitude of
different purposes and so what are some
of the other ways that you can actually
use uh this wallet attribution um for
either commercial purposes or for
individual investors well I would say
this this is a very big right so like in
in traditional Finance it is um uh
almost impossible to find Reliable
market indicators right indicators that
are predictive of where the Market's
going to go the one we're looking at
here is is an example that very clearly
um does accomplish that um so some of
the things we're working on with our
customers is that uh there's a lot of
other ones like that that exist Within
These markets um you know for someone
coming from the trafi world like that's
kind of Unthinkable that there could be
like um these kind of hidden uh diamonds
just sitting around but there there
truly are within Bitcoin and crypto and
so uh a lot of what we do with our data
is tried to identify some of those those
indicators and those can be a lot of
different things um so that's one of the
ways and some of the primary customers
we're working with right now is helping
people to identify trading
opportunities um if we're looking kind
of more generally and kind of more
broadly as to really where this whole
ecosystem is going well like the
coinbase Commerce um addresses that
we've identified um excuse me coin not
coinbase Commerce coinbase custody
addresses we've identified those ones
are particularly significant if uh if
you start under the assumption that
um uptake of these ETFs is going to be a
big driver of Bitcoin in the future um
people aren't necessarily going to know
like in real time like you know uh how
much buying of these is happening and
where they're going and how much Bitcoin
is is needing to be purchased in order
to back the ETFs that are being created
um but that's all stuff that we can
track on Chan so over the course of the
year and even right now that's something
that we're looking at very closely is uh
movements and growth of the size of the
Bitcoin sitting in coinbase Commerce as
a as a proxy for um the uptake of the
ETF got it and then when you look at uh
these wallets it seems like uh there's a
lot of Bitcoin that hasn't moved in a
very very long time is there any way to
determine is that Bitcoin lost or is
that Bitcoin just in the hands of you
know people with very strong kind of
diamond hands yeah yeah uh well yeah
this is another big one that we're
looking at as well because you know if
when you look at at the the size of
these of the companies that have
launched these ETFs guys like Black Rock
Fidelity vanck um uh you know lots of
really big companies that that are
thinking really big with this right
Black Rock didn't launch this to make a
few million bucks right Black Rock black
rock launches new product to make huge
amounts of money they have trillions
under management so I think a big open
question here is and when you're trying
to answer the question of well will like
the buying of these ETFs which I expect
be substantial um that for every Bitcoin
bought in ETF there needs to be some
actual Bitcoin that someone is willing
to part with and um so a big question is
like how easily is that Bitcoin gonna
come out and you're you're entirely
right you have um of 21 million Bitcoin
that is the final number that will be
mined of all time uh just right off the
top you have a million of it that's
owned by Satoshi and that's not going
anywhere um you also have other big
chunks of it that are lost for various
other reasons I think there was a big
chunk that's sitting in a landmine
somewhere or landfill somewhere
um right and you have you have lots of
other chunks that for various other
reasons are likely never to come out and
I've seen some quantifications of that
number and I I've heard two million is
thrown out as as a um a rough estimate
but I think you start looking beyond
that and then you have say you know the
Bitcoin that I have sitting on my
treasure wallet which is in my closet
somewhere and you know which I may not
even be focused on crypto right now so I
may not be likely to you know no matter
how high the price goes to go in and
sell it and I think um you know as if
the start the price starts ticking
higher and feel like we're in a build
like a bull run I think you also kind of
get this uh reverse scenario where
higher price doesn't necessarily make
people more likely to sell it could
actually make you more likely to want to
hold
it um so what's amazing about Bitcoin is
that we can actually survey the entire
ecosystem the entire economy of all of
these positions and um start to put
together some metrics on like how these
different positions respond to diff
different uh price movements so that's a
a long way of saying I don't have an
answer right now on how easily that
Bitcoin will come out but um I think
it's a very relevant question for like
what happens with this ecosystem going
forward yeah that makes uh ton of sense
well may maybe you can uh walk us
through the inscriptions which obviously
was a huge part of Q4 there was tons of
uh explosion in fees and I think a lot
of people didn't understand or see this
coming but being able to see onchain
happening there is pretty
enlightening yeah absolutely
inscriptions were one of the most
exciting developments at least from an
onchain perspective uh throughout
2023 um so take a step back what our
inscriptions our inscriptions are uh
kind of a newly discovered feature if
you will of the Bitcoin blockchain was
created uh through a loophole uh in the
end of 2021 soft Fork which was called
tap r uh it enables users to basically
store text media Etc in the metadata
that's attached to the smallest numbered
units of a Bitcoin called a Satoshi
there's 100 million Satoshi in every
Bitcoin um and so U you might have seen
Eric wall or or uh udy kind of pushing
ordinals widely on on Twitter they've
caused kind of a ton of controversy uh
within the the Bitcoin Community if you
will uh some people feel that uh they're
a detriment to the network because they
increase fees and increase the amount of
uh data that you need to download to run
a node other people say that they're
great for the network because they raise
fees uh and then also you know kind of
take away the the long-term security
budget issue that a lot of people have
voiced about Bitcoin reality is the
answer is probably somewhere in the
middle but nonetheless uh as activity
for inscriptions has picked up it's
become a a bigger and bigger
conversation kind of within the within
the community um when we look at the
amount of fees that have been generated
uh upwards of $200 million of fees uh
for the Bitcoin Network U just from the
transactional activity around ordinals
which uh of course benefits minors
directly although it maybe makes the uh
kind of you know small transaction uh
for you know if you're trying to buy a
cup of coffee or something like that
with the Bitcoin base chain which I'm of
the belief that that's not necessarily
what the base chain is supposed to be
used for uh it does make you know
obviously uh you know transactional cost
slightly higher for for those types of
uh those types of transactions but um
overall the The increased amount of fees
benefits Miners and then in theory that
should you know create a higher uh
incentive for for miners to want
continue to bring on more machines to to
capture those fees and then as a
byproduct of that secure the Bitcoin
Network and so one fun fact was this is
no longer the case as uh fees have drawn
down over the last month by about 80%
since when we pulled some of this data
initially uh but at one point uh in
December Bitcoin reached the number one
blockchain by transaction fees over the
last seven days uh and 30 days and I
don't think this has happened at least
in in in a very long time I'm not sure
if I've ever seen that happen uh usually
eth dominates uh the the kind of number
one spot for for blockchains uh by
transaction fees and so just kind of a
tesate uh to the amount of activity
that's taken place in kind of the frenzy
around inscriptions that we've seen uh
at one point also inscriptions made up
over 25% of of daily fees on the Bitcoin
Network so um this is something that I
think is exciting to to continue to
watch for a couple reasons um but you
know I would expect that if we have kind
of a raging speculative bull market
you'll probably see uh inscriptions
continue to to persist in full force uh
you know we saw kind of the uh
speculative bubble if you will around
nfts in 2021 and I think there's uh
there's a decent probability that we may
see something similar around uh
inscriptions and then I guess to kind of
segue um inscriptions into the next
chart that we have is looking at hash
rate so you know as I as I just
mentioned um as fees are increased on
the Bitcoin Network it creates a
stronger incentive for people to or for
miners to uh continue to add more
machines onto the network and try to
compete uh to increase the amount of uh
Hash Hash rate that they're generating
to compete um for uh the amount of fees
so so that they can increase their
revenues um as we can see in this chart
U hash rate has just continue to
absolutely RI throughout 2023 uh it
makes the China mining band of of Summer
of 2021 just look like a blip on the
chart uh and so you know I definitely
don't think this is fully driven by
inscriptions um but you know if you do
have kind of an elevated uh regime of
fees for for the network that should
continue to kind of um you know further
further advance that that rise and hash
rate that we saw throughout the
year now when we see so much of um the
minor activity we also know that they
outperformed Bitcoin during 2023 uh in
terms of the financial return should we
expect continuations of these Trends hat
rate going up fees going up uh minor
outperforming the underlying or could
this have maybe been an Aly and actually
the outperformance by the minor of the
underlying is something that people
shouldn't expect moving forward well I
think typically if you go back and look
over the last couple years miners
usually trade with beta to the
underlying Bitcoin and so what does that
mean it basically just means that when
Bitcoin goes up the miners tend to go up
more when Bitcoin goes down miners tend
to go down more um and so you know with
that there's a ton of volatility around
these Miners and I think one kind of
mental model at least that that I've
used for thinking about allocating to
miners is uh they're similar to a call
option on on BTC so you know if you
think BTC trades at call it 100K plus
over the next you know 12 to 16 months
um you know miners are probably going to
outperform that just given the way that
that they trade relative to BTC um you
know in the short term we're recording
this on you know January 22nd you've
seen some reversion miners went on a
pretty aggressive run uh it seems like
um it seems like maybe they were kind of
being used as proxies for front running
some of the ETF launches and filings and
launches um and then also uh as I
mentioned a minute ago um we've seen the
the fees that were elevated over the
last call it month and a half kind of
come down they're down about 80% month
over month so we've seen you know some
of that that inscriptions activity that
was fueling fees higher cool off in the
short term um but you know when I think
about maybe allocating to miners the
kind of general generalistic that I use
in my mind is they're very similar to um
call options on BTC and then you kind of
have that added X Factor of you know if
we do see kind of this prolonged regime
of ordinal activity or they go on some
type of you know speculative runs
similar to how nfts on ethereum did in
2021 um you know that would
significantly increase fees uh for
miners across the board I mean just to
kind of put it into into perspective uh
in the middle of uh I guess I guess on
average uh across Q3 2023 fees hung out
around you know 750k to a million
dollars a day um during kind of the peak
of of this recent kind of wave of of
ordinals in December fees reached
upwards of $23 million which was the
highest single day of of fees ever
generated for the network and so you
know you think okay if this persists for
two or three months especially you know
again during a bull market um where you
also have you know just people um you
know using the the Bitcoin Network U
more in general uh that could that could
be uh pretty effective for for some of
these uh public mining equities so it's
just one thing I think uh to continue to
keep an eye on for sure Alex let's talk
about stable coins which is the last
part of the report but to me is maybe
the most interesting part just given uh
a couple years ago no one thought that
stable coins would be that big of a deal
now it's a major part of uh the crypto
ecosystem and maybe even Global Finance
what are some of the takeaways based on
this
analysis uh well yes uh stable coins are
certainly the backbone of gii uh the uh
fastest grown uh part of the crypto
system today um and uh uh we have two
charts in the report uh covering stable
coins uh one is showing uh change in
total stable uh coin market
capitalization and the other one is uh
velocity aggregate velocity of money for
uh the stable coins so uh what we see
through through about
2023 um the market cap of stable coins
mostly contracted with that Trend
reversing only in the fourth quarter uh
of uh the last year so what what
happened uh uh can be attributed to um
uh several Trends first of all uh we had
um the uh silicon value Bank Run on the
bank scare in the beginning of
2023 uh which also affected uh the other
two uh big so-called crypto Banks
silvergate and signature that was also
seized by the feds before uh running the
bank really started we know that for
example Circle uh and coin base uh
deposited uh funds back in usdc uh
stable coin
with silicon valy bank and
silvergate bank which at some point
resulted in the Panic surrounding uh
that particular stable coin uh trading
with a discount um as wide as 10% that's
care resulted um in usdc um market cap
reduction through the year where uh uh
that stable coin was mostly redeemed
uh which was uh partially upset by the
increase in tether market capitalization
the the other
Trend uh that contributed to the uh
reduction market cap uh uh was the um
shutdown of uh binance USD as uh binance
uh Native stable coin admin mined by
paxus and paxus was affected by the same
silicon valy Banks here because paxus
main uh depositary institution was
Signature Bank which was uh seized by
Federal Reserve as I already mentioned
so right now bu USD is in Redemption
only mode and no new units are being
issued uh the uh units of BD are only uh
being redeemed but uh yeah in the end it
all work worked out uh in the fourth
quarter we've seen expansion of uh
stable uh stable coin market cap which
basically means the expansion of Fiat uh
Capital base in the crypto ecosystem
which uh is a sign of things to come
we're looking forward
towards um Bitcoin housing to really
kick off the bull market and because uh
stable coin uh market cap expansion is
normally Associated through with the
speculative phases uh the bull market as
you can see on the chart so when I look
at these stable coins one of the things
that jumps out to me is
um internationally there's been lots of
adoption but also where they've been
adopted has been pretty interesting you
know usdt on Tron is not exactly where
many people thought there would be uh
adoption of stable coins or or any of
these products but that seems to be a
very popular use case how do you kind of
decipher maybe the narratives versus
this is just the onchain data tells a
story that is hard to argue with because
it's you know more objective and more
kind of factual this episode is brought
to you by bet online do you like making
a profit from sports betting well set
yourself up to take home the most profit
possible using crypto to fund your
sports betting casino and account at
betonline.ag you can avoid costly
transaction fees get your payouts
lightning fast and do it all securely
and anonymously with the highest deposit
and withdrawal limits in the industry if
you want to get in on the action do it
the smart way with crypto at
betonline.ag head to the website sign up
with promo code pomp 100 to get 100%
bonus on your crypto deposit today if
you go and you deposit they'll give you
100% bonus if you use promo code pomp
100 bet online the game starts here
betonline.com AG go check them out today
uh yes you certainly stable coins uh
have different use cases and uh because
Tron is a relatively lowcost chain it
became super popular uh in Asia for uh
electronic transactions by passing uh
the global banking system but not just
in Asia for example you know one of our
co-workers just mentioned that you you
could uh you can pay with usdt on Tron
for taxi ride in Venezuela for example
so T so tther is
actually uh seen the most adoption as uh
payment rails whereas usdc is the most
popular uh uh defi instrument
representing Fiat dollar just to add on
and my my thoughts on this the uh you
know I think the use the volume that's
traded on Tron is roughly similar to the
volume that's traded on ethereum which
was a stat that really blew my mind when
I first heard that because Tron is not
something that's used for a whole lot
else so I think what it represents in um
the defi or uh stable coin Space is
really I think what Alex alluded to
which is like a shadow banking system
and that could be money laundering it
could be Capital flight from out of one
country into another uh in Venezuela for
instance
um but um I think that's what that
segment of the stable coin ecosystem is
got it and and then maybe another you
know kind of question is like as we
enter this world where uh there's
multiple assets you know you see Larry
Fink on National Television talking
about uh tokenizing different you know
kind of traditional assets Etc will we
be able to use some of these same
Technologies to track on chain the same
movements Etc and so you know know a
technology like elementus has uh now
kind of can evaluate the entire
Financial Market if everything goes on
chain yeah and it's it's a really
interesting concept and and I might even
take it a step bigger that um you know
some some of the conversations we're
having right now are with um generative
Ventures whose thesis is really on this
new digital economy that's forming and
that's kind of some combination of of
blockchain technology and artificial
intelligence um and
yeah what like what we're working on
together right now is um quantifying
some of these base economic metrics such
as a GDP right that you know you can
look at how much Bitcoin on a very raw
level is transacted on a daily basis but
um quite different if you're talking
about people exchanging One financial
asset for another for speculative
purposes versus somebody paying for some
kind of good or service and like the uh
the number of use cases that fit into
that second category of um like actual
economic transfers so real value being
created through the blockchain is really
starting to
proliferate um so uh you know these are
the conversations we're having I think
it's a really exciting prospect the idea
of um of an entire economy where um well
everything can be calculated very very
precisely from bottoms up as opposed to
the traditional economy where economists
are looking at sort of big picture
indicators and making estimates of
things um that I think yeah as as the
use of blockchain proliferates into real
economic use cases um yeah the level of
transparency is really going to be a you
know a big shift and it's going to be
something very
different yeah I completely agree with
Max you know the thing that kind of
captivated my mind a few years ago kind
of initially diving into onchain Data
was this idea of if Bitcoin is to become
kind of the global uh settle layer for
everything um you know it becomes very
much akin to looking at maybe you know
the St Louis uh fed data right as
opposed to just looking at you know what
are onchain flows so that I know how to
speculatively trade it over like a
couple month time Horizon so I think you
know the onchain data will definitely
evolve from as Max eloquently just said
uh from maybe being used for kind of uh
uh Market
analyzing uh or you know kind of
speculative purposes around coming to
conclusions about you know the state of
the market or different Dynamics around
the market to more kind of viewing
holistically where this kind of new uh
world is with with Bitcoin as kind of
the the settlement layer and then I
guess one other piece to to tag on is
you know as uh as you know you have
things such as you know securitization
of of different um I'm sorry as you have
the the tokenization of of different
Securities or things brought on chain um
all of a sudden you're able to kind of
view these things in a in a level of of
granularity that you were never able to
do before you I think one example uh we
touched on towards the beginning is
inscriptions right like um you know you
could see in real time that minor fees
were going up for you know these
publicly traded uh equities but you know
that wouldn't have shown uh until the
end of the quarter whenever whenever the
company released their earnings so um
you know I think holistically we'll be
you know kind of evolve into um you know
a way to view kind of granularity of of
uh the economy itself that you've never
had before as well as uh you know
different different companies or or
assets that are brought on chain in in a
level of granularity that you've never
had before yeah and you know one other
just aspect I I would add on to this is
um you know something that I way some
way that I see that a lot of these
different trends that ties them all
together is um well you have like ETF
stuff happening right now which is a way
of
taking digital assets and packaging them
for buyers who really are not set up to
hold digital assets um but you have some
of this the tokenization of real assets
is actually just the reverse of that
it's it's tokenize it's tokenizing
traditional assets for buyers that can't
hold uh traditional assets but can hold
digital assets so in both cases kind of
a bridging of the gap between
traditional markets and uh or
traditional financial markets and crypto
financial markets and you might throw
stable in there as um you know another
element to that and um well a lot of the
new trends that we're seeing um dpin
would be another one where it really
does feel like some of the um yeah the
new developments that we're seeing are
less sort of crypto self-contained and
much more um connective between uh
traditional and um and digital so my
last question I guess is uh
Max maybe you can just if you had to
describe someone what does elementus do
what is the technology obviously I'm
very bullish uh I'm an investor and
think highly of both the team the
technology and what you guys are
building but like how do you describe it
to someone we help people make better
smarter more informed decisions on the
blockchain and how do you do that uh
well we we do that through data so uh we
can help inform people of information
that happens in the blockchain coming
coming from traditional Finance right as
a as a Trader but even all the people
around me that I was working with
everything in finance is um well
information is the fuel of Finance uh
for understanding risk for understanding
opportunities um those are very
sophisticated markets as this Market
starts to approach traditional Finance
involves and I think um there's you know
a lot of open-ended questions but I
think some things you can guess pretty
well how it's going to evolve and some
things are going to look quite like
traditional Finance um the data piece is
going to become increasingly important
and so um with our data we can help
people to understand risks better so
that some of these internal teams within
investment Banks can go to their
managers confidently and be able to
articulate the the um the opportunity
they want the risks that it poses and be
able to quantify that with numbers um or
for those teams that are looking around
for opportunities and really want
something to focus on we can help them
do the explor work toine those um yeah
and just generally speaking um we can
help people to have a much closer pulse
on on the market so being able to
understand what's happening offchain you
know a lot of news makes its way to
crypto Twitter which is tends to be I
think most people's source of
information and it's a it's a great one
um and there's a lot of stuff you can
learn on there you can't learn on the
blockchain but there's also a lot of
information and a lot of things that
happen on the blockchain that don't make
its way out such as
FTX you know that's one that could have
been identified you know a year or more
before it blew up as with uh some of the
other big companies that that blew out
so
um we help people make better smarter uh
better educ educated Decisions by using
our
data and maybe we can just go around
real quick uh will where can people find
you on the
internet uh sure first of all you could
uh check out our research firm
reflexivity research uh at reflexivity
research.com you check me out on Twitter
at wcl
II awesome Alex if somebody wants to get
in in uh touch with you element website
is over with elementus doio and uh my
Twitter handle is a
m amazing
there's Max you take us home where can
they find you H well if you want to find
me on Twitter uh I am
Galore Max
amazing I appreciate all of you the
report is incredible if anyone wants to
go check it out I highly suggest you do
it uh reading through it is uh quite
informative so we'll definitely do this
again in the future when you guys should
do another one excellent yeah thank you
very much Anthony